We have a blank space plus 1/16
equal to 3/2.
I recommend that you stop the video and understand yourself
what's in the empty place.
How many plus 1/16 is equal to 3/2?
All right.
Let's solve it together.
Something that maybe will simplify things,
is to express 1/16
and 3/2 with a common denominator.
When we think of a common denominator,
we are looking for a number that is multiple
of the denominators here.
To our luck 16 is divided into 2.
At 16, so this is the common multiple,
or at least a total of multiple of 16 and 2.
There are other numbers that are generally multiples, but the least
of them is 16 by 1, which is divided into 2.
Let's try both
fractions.
Let's write this equation so that these fractions
have a denominator 16.
This is obviously recorded like this.
Let's save this.
We'll get
empty space plus 1/16,
1/16,
equal to, to see,
to write 3/2 as something on 16.
To get a denominator 16 of 2,
we have to multiply by 8.
Then we have to multiply the numerator by 8.
3 by 8 equals 24.
At this point you can do it in your mind.
Blank space plus 1/16 is equal to 24/16.
We can say, well, this can ...
We can count this as a sixteenth number.
How many sixteen plus 1/16
will be equal to 24/16?
Well 23/16.
That's 23/16, I add 1/16
and I get 24/16.
Another way to think about it
is when ...
In fact, we have already done so
in the first step, you can say,
that if something plus 1/16 is equal to 3/2,
you can say that this empty place
will be equal to
3/2
minus 1/16.
This is another way to solve the problem.
If something plus 1/16 is equal to 3/2,
then this thing will be equal to 3/2
minus 1/16.
And we know it will be equal to ...
3/2, we already know that
is equal to 24/16.
So 24/16 minus 1/16,
which we have already seen,
that is 23/16, which is equal to ...
I will write it again, 23 on 16.
Let's figure out another example.
Here is a little different.
I have an empty space minus 3/4 equal to 2/3.
There are several ways to think about it.
If an empty space minus 3/4 is equal to 2/3,
one way to think about this is to say,
that the empty space will be equal to
2/3 plus 3/4.
Plus 3/4.
How will this be equal?
Again, I can write down the two fractions
with a common denominator.
Which is the smallest total of 3 and 4?
I can check the multiples at 4 and continue
to increase them until I find a number,
which is divided into 3 without residue.
4 is not divisible by 3.
8 is not divisible by 3.
12 is divided into 3.
In fact, 12 is 3 in 4.
Then I can write the two fractions as something on 12.
This will be equal to ...
To get 12 out of 3, we multiply by 4.
We must multiply by 4 and the numerator.
2 in 4 is 8.
2/3 equals 8/12.
This will be equal to 8/12 plus,
and 3/4 will be equal to
how much on 12?
To get 12 out of 4, we need to multiply by 3,
so we have to multiply by 3 and the numerator.
3 in 3 is 9.
How will this be equal?
Equals to what is equal to
8/12 plus 9/12, which will be
8 plus 9 - 17.
17/12.
You get 17/12 minus 3/4
is equal to 2/3.
Another way you can do this,
is to keep it as it was,
and say, well, let me write
this, but I will write it down,
by putting together a common denominator of fractions.
We have already said that the common denominator,
which we will use is 12, the smallest.
We can use 24 or something bigger.
But this is the smallest common multiple,
which will make things a little simpler.
And 3/4, we'll write them down
such as 9/12.
9 on 12 is equal to ...
A 2/3 we can record as 8 on 12.
You can assume it will be
some number twelve.
Blank space on 12 minus 9/12 is equal to 8/12.
If I have an empty space from something minus 9 of this thing
and I'm left 8 of this thing,
it will mean that at the beginning I have 17 of this thing.
17/12 minus 9/12 equals 8/12.
In both cases you get 17/12.